here's an African proverb that goes the
Lions story will never be known as long
as the hunter is the one to tell it more
than a racial conversation we need a
racial literacy to decode the politics
of racial threat in America key to this
literacy is a forgotten truth that the
more that we understand that our
cultural differences represent the power
to heal the centuries of racial
discrimination dehumanization and
illness both of my parents were African
American my father was born in southern
Delaware my mother in North Philadelphia
and these two places are as different
from each other as East is from West as
New York City is from Montgomery Alabama
my father's way of dealing with racial
conflict was to have my brother Brian my
sister Christy and I in church would
seem like 24 hours a day seven days a
week
if anybody bothered us because of the
color of our skin he believed that you
should pray for them knowing that God
would get them back in the end you could
say that his racial coping approach was
spiritual for later on one day like
Martin Luther King my mother's coping
approach was a little different she was
you could say more relational right now
like in your face right now
more like Malcolm X she was raised from
neighborhoods in which there was racial
violence and segregation where she was
chased out of neighborhoods and she
exactly violence to chase others out of
hers when she came to southern Delaware
she thought she had come to a foreign
country she'd understand anybody
particularly the the few black and brown
folks who were physically deferential
and verbally differential in the
presence of whites not my mother when
she went to go somewhere she walked she
didn't care what you thought and she
pissed a lot of people off with her
cultural style before we get into the
supermarket she would give us the talk
don't ask for nothing don't touch
nothing do you understand what I'm
saying to you
I don't care if all the other children
are climbing the walls they're not my
children do you understand what I'm
saying to you in three-part harmony yes
mom before we'd get into the supermarket
that talk was all we needed how many of
you ever got that talk how many of you
ever give that talk how many of you ever
give that talk today my mother didn't
give us the talk because she was worried
about money or reputation or us
misbehaving we never misbehaved with too
scared we were in church 24 hours a day
seven days a week
she gave us that talk to remind us that
some people in the world would interpret
us as misbehaving just by being black
not every parent has to worry about
their children being misjudged because
of the color of their skin just by
breathing so we get into the supermarket
and people look at us stare at us as if
we just stole something every now and
then a sales person would do something
or say something because they were
pissed with our cultural style and I'm
it usually happen at the conveyor belt
and the worst thing they could do was to
throw our food into the bag and when
that happened it was on my mother began
to tell him who they were who their
family was where to go how fast to get
there if you haven't been cursed out by
my mother you haven't lived the person
would be on the floor writhing in utter
decay and decomposition whimpering in a
pool of racial shame now both my parents
were Christians the difference is my
father prayed before a racial conflict
and my mother prayed after
there is a time if you use both of their
strategies if you use them in the right
time in the right way but it's never a
time right there's a time for
conciliation there's a time for
confrontation but it's never a time to
freeze up like a deer in the headlights
and it's never a time to lash out and
heedless thoughtless anger the lesson in
this is that when it comes to race
relations sometimes we got to know how
to pray think through process prepare
and other times we got to know how to
push how to do something and I'm afraid
that neither of these two skills
preparing pushing are prevalent in our
society today if you look at the
neuroscience research which says that
when we are racially threatened our
brains go on lockdown and we dehumanize
black and brown people
our brains imagine that children and
adults are older than they really are
larger than they really are and closer
than they really are
when we're at our worst we convince
ourselves that they don't deserve
affection or protection at the racial
empowerment collaborative we know that
some of the most scariest moments are
racial encounters some of the most
scariest moments that people will ever
face if you look at the police
encounters that have led to some
wrongful deaths of mostly Native
Americans and African Americans in this
country they've lasted about two minutes
within 60 seconds our brains
go on lockdown and when we're unprepared
we overreact
at best we shut down at worse we shoot
first and ask no questions
imagine if we could reduce the intensity
of threat within those 60 seconds and
keep our brains from going on lockdown
imagine how many children would get to
come home from school or 7-eleven
without getting expelled or shocked
imagine how many mothers and fathers
wouldn't have to cry
racial socialization can help young
people negotiate 60-second encounters
but it's going to take more than a chat
it requires a race of literacy now how
do parents have this conversations and
what is a racial literacy thank you for
asking a racial literacy involves the
ability to read recast and resolve a
racially stressful encounter reading
involves recognizing when a racial
moment happens and noticing our stress
reactions to it recasting involves
taking mindfulness and reducing my
tsunami interpretation of this moment
and reducing it to a mountain climbing
experience one that is from impossible
situation to one that is much more
doable and challenging resolving a
racially stressful encounter involves
being able to make a healthy decision
that is not an under reaction where I
pretend that didn't bother me or an
overreaction where I exaggerate the
moment now we can teach parents and
children how to read recast and resolve
using a mindfulness strategy we call
calculate locate communicate breathe in
exhale stay with me calculate ask what
feeling am i having right now and how
intense is it on a scale of 1 to 10
locate ask where my body do I feel it
and be specific like the Native American
girl at a Chicago fifth grade school
said to me I feel I'm angry at a nine
because I'm the only Native American and
I can feel it in my stomach like a bunch
of butterflies are fighting with each
other so much so that they fly up into
my throat and choke me the more details
you can be the easier it is to reduce
that spot communicate ask what self-talk
and what images are coming in my mind
and if you really want help try
breathing in and exhaling slowly now
with the help of my many colleagues at
the racial empowerment collaborative we
use in the moment stress reduction in
several research and therapy
projects one project is where we use
basketball to help youth manage their
emotions during 60-second eruptions on
the court another project with my with
the help of my colleagues Loretta and
John Jamaat we leverage the cultural
style of african-american barbershops
where we train black barbers to be
health educators in two areas one to
safely reduce the sexual risk in their
partner relationships and the other to
stop retaliation violence the cool part
is the barbers use their cultural style
to deliver this health education to 18
to 24 year old men while they're cutting
their hair another project is where we
teach teachers how to read recast and
resolve stressful moments in the
classroom and a final project in which
we teach parents and students and their
children separately to understand their
racial traumas before we bring them
together to problem-solve daily
microaggressions now racially literate
conversations with our children can be
healing but it takes practice and I know
some of you are say in practice practice
which other my practice yes we are
talking about practice I have two sons
my oldest Brian is 26 and my youngest
Julian is 12 and we do not have time to
talk about how that happened
but when I think of them they are still
babies to me and I worry every day that
the world will miss judge them in August
of 2013
Julian who was eight at the time and I
were folding laundry which in and of
itself is such a rare occurrence I
should have known something strange was
going to happen on the TV were Trayvon
Martin's parents and they were crying
because of the acquittal of George
Zimmerman and Julian was glued to the TV
he had a thousand questions and I was
not prepared he wanted to know why why
would a grown man stalk and hunt down
and kill us unarmed 17-year old boy and
I did not know what to say the best
thing that could come out of my mouth
was Julian sometimes in this world there
are people who look down on black and
brown people and do not treat them and
children - do not treat them as human he
interpreted the whole situation as sad I
will shoot you because I'm skinny
exactly like you it's like they're
saying that you don't look right on soy
as I have the right to disrespect you
yeah and that's what we call it and we
call that racism Julie and yes some
people other people can wear a hoodie
and nothing happens to them but you and
Trayvon Mike and that's why that's why
daddy wants you to be safe and that's
why so you mean like one one you said
other people you mean
if Trayvon was a white there you
wouldn't be disrespected
yes Julian daddy met white people when I
said other people alright so there was a
way in which I was so awkward in the
beginning but once I started getting my
rhythm and my groove I started talking
about stereotypes and issues of
discrimination and just when I was
getting my groove on Julian interrupted
me a child or boy that is wrong doesn't
matter who does it what so he interrupts
me to tell me a story about when he was
racially threatened at a swimming pool
with a friend by two grown white men
which his mother confirmed and I felt
happy that he was able to talk about it
felt like he was getting it we moved
from the sadness of Trayvon's parents
and started talking about George
Zimmerman's parents which I read in a
magazine condoned the stalking of
Trayvon and Julian's reaction to me was
priceless and made me feel like he was
getting well I think they basically felt
that he was justified to follow wonder
yeah I think that's wrong so they're
saying he has to write the foul a black
kid getting a fight with him and shoot
him as Julian was getting it I started
to lose it because in my mind I was
thinking what if my Julian or Brian was
Trayvon I calculated my anger at a 10
I found located my right leg was shaking
uncontrollably like I was running and in
my mind's eye I could see somebody
chasing Julian and I was chasing them
and the only thing that could come out
of my mouth was if anybody method tries
to bother my child if anybody tries to
bother my child
because what I'm giving well they're
gonna get you because they might have
what well you know what I'm gonna call
police to like I should but to feel like
I want to get them but you can't you
gotta be right you can't just you can't
just don't say some people feel like I
must a see my son I don't like that but
I got you right you got to be careful
and you got it you gotta be careful
you never know what some crazy people
will think about you so as long as you
believe you're beautiful like daddy
believes you're beautiful and handsome
and mommy believes you're beautiful and
handsome and smart and you deserve to be
on this planet this is happy and
beautiful as smart as you want to be you
could do anything you want maybe racial
socialization is not just what parents
teach their children it's also how
children respond to what their parents
teach is my child prepared can they
recognize when a racial elephant shows
up in a room can they reduce their
tsunami interpretation down to a
mountain climbing adventure that they
can engage and not run away can they
make a health and just decision in 60
seconds can I can you yes we can we can
build healthier relationships around
race if we learn to calculate locate
communicate breathe and exhale in the
most in the middle of our most
threatening moments when we come face to
face with our less ourselves if you take
the centuries a racial rage that boils
up in all of our bodies minds and souls
and anything that affects our bodies
minds and souls affects our health we
could probably use gun control for our
hearts I just want what all parents want
for their children when we're not around
affection and protection when police and
teachers see my children I want them to
imagine their own because I believe if
you see our children as your children
you won't shoot them with racial
literacy and yes practice we can decode
the racial trauma from our stories and
our healing will come in the telling but
we must always we must never forget that
our cultural differences are full of
affection and protection and remember
always that the Lyons story will never
be known as long as the hunter is the
one to tell it thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]